well I'm finishing up some of the books
that i read that i'm working on in terms
of wall street reform so there's a very
good book called 13 bankers by simon
johnson and that's a book that deals
with the fact that we have four or five
six very huge financial institutions in
this country and the implications of
what that means when you have a few
banks controlling half of the assets of
the United States of America I think
Johnson does a good job about halfway
through with that book and I want to
complete it I am also stumbling through
a book on the life of Franklin Delano
Roosevelt called traitor to his class by
HW brands and what's interesting about
that book is in the 1930s in many ways
we faced the enormous um of the same
type of enormous problems that the
country is facing right now and it's
interesting to see how Roosevelt dealt
with the Great Depression and all the
problems associated with that as opposed
to how Obama is dealing with the
enormous problems that he inherited they
have very different styles so that's a
book that I am enjoying there is a
another book that I intend to read by
good friend of mine from Vermont named
Bill McKibben bill is one of the great
environmental writers of our time and
he's written a new book called Earth e
EI EI r th suggesting that the old
planet earth that we knew EA r th no
longer is in existence we've done so
much damage that in a sense we need to
respec and bill is is a great writer in
describing what is happening to our
planet the implications of that and how
we might go forward in a different way
to
reverse some of the horrendous
ecological that disaster damage that we
currently are facing